[Música]
y en directo a Vamos hasta Ecuador donde
hay nuevos problemas para el presidente
Guillermo lasso una comisión
multipartidista del Congreso recomendó
un juicio político contra el mandatario
por presuntos delitos de corrupción en
el llamado caso encuentro para ampliar
esta noticia saludamos en Quito a
nuestro corresponsal Gustavo Ortega
Gustavo muy buenas noches cuéntenos Qué
fue exactamente lo que se aprobó Y por
qué se investigar eso
buena noche para ti Bueno luego de un
año y nueve meses en la asamblea
nacional intenta por segunda vez Cesar
sus funciones el presidente de la
república la primera ocasión sucedió el
28 de junio de 2022 a 16 días de la
movilizaciones indígenas en aquel caso
no se encontraron los votos cuando se
intentó
destituir al presidente de la república
por crisis políticas y grave conmoción
ahora se realiza esta intento nuevamente
de César al presidente de la república
relacionado al caso encuentro de luego
de ello pero qué es el caso encuentro
esa es una investigación procesal donde
la fiscalía general del estado ha
mantenido una investigación ha dicho que
con buen tiempo que estaría relacionada
con una presunta red de corrupción esto
comenzó como una investigación de una
presunta red de corrupción
específicamente en el sector eléctrico
Pero ha cambiado se ha convertido en una
investigación por narcotráfico la
fiscalía general del estado ha dicho y
que existen hasta el momento tres
personas involucrada se habla de Hernán
meluque quien el presidente de la
república lo habría designado como el
presidente al director o las empresas
públicas se le habría otorgado
superpoderes como Así dice la oposición
De igual forma también se habla de Rubén
echeverres quien sería el supuesto
vínculo con el gobierno se habla de un
gobierno paralelo con en nexos con La
Mafia el narcotráfico la fiscal general
del estado habla sobre una mafia
albanesa y el narcotráfico se habla
también sobre presuntos financiamientos
a campañas políticas y De igual forma
personas vinculadas con el entorno
íntimo y familiar de el presidente de la
república por el cual luego de un largo
debate se ha aprobado se ha recomendado
el pleno de la asamblea nacional un
juicio político en contra del presidente
de la república Gustavo Sabemos que esta
medida que se aprobó hoy no es
vinculante Entonces qué va a pasar Cuál
es el siguiente paso en este proceso
sí efectivamente Andrés es un informe
que no es vincularte hacia hace una
recomendación no quiere decir que se
realizará el día de mañana es un proceso
largo que debe cumplir con todo un
protocolo y una cantidad de fases para
poder cumplirse qué va a suceder Bueno A
partir de este momento debe pasar debe
contar inclusive con su paso por la
corte constitucional se debe debe tener
también una resolución sobre la
admisibilidad es el término correcto que
se utiliza para la corte constitucional
luego de ello inclusive debe ir a la
asamblea nacional debe pasar por el
consejo de la Administración legislativa
el cal Es el órgano que califica o no la
convocatoria de la asamblea nacional
debe ir al pleno de la asamblea nacional
debe contar con los votos tanto de la
corte constitucional seis de los nueves
magistrados nueve integrantes de la
corte constitucional como también votos
en el cal el órgano cualificador igual
forma también debe contar con las dos
terceras partes del pleno del parlamento
92 votos para censurar y destituir así
al presidente de la república